and i think it's just getting ridiculous
now
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
frances foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is the show for you if you want
honest conversations
with fascinating people our brilliant
and returning guest today is one of
britain's finest comedians
simon evans welcome back to trigonometry
thank you very much thank you for having
me back and you both look
extraordinarily well
better even i would say than you did two
years ago fantastic
thank you the log down has done us well
absolutely we are the donald trump's
mid-range course and a nice nice little
setup there for the rest of the
conversation
but simon if you don't mind me revealing
this a few weeks ago when
the whole bbc left-wing right-wing bias
thing was being discussed
you called me up but we had a phone
conversation and you were sounding
increasingly irate as the conversation
went on maybe
your new diet was kicking in not enough
carbs or whatever it was
but but you felt quite strongly about
some of the things that were being said
at the time
yeah and it's obviously since we last
spoke to you the culture war has
accelerated it's become much more
part of everybody's lives so just talk
to us about
your feelings on the whole thing how was
presented there was articles written
about how the no funny right-wing
comedians or
all this sort of thing yeah it's
absolutely true and my wife incidentally
would agree with your diagnosis that
it's due to a lack of carbohydrates but
i
actually feel much better for having
eliminated those i feel the clarity
which i wish i had 30 35 years ago
i would say that something i mean i
don't know
it's a cliche isn't it to say that
something snapped or something do what i
mean that these things are incremental
they change over time but
there have been lots of iterations about
that discussion
is right-wing comedy even possible is it
desirable should is representation
important is it the equivalent of having
on a climate change denier on to the
today program do we need to hear from
piers corbin every time
program or report comes out of the ipc
but i do
feel that there was a dishonesty
in the last iteration that angered me
there was there was
i on this this podcast and i've been on
a couple where we've discussed this kind
of thing before i've had
uh five series of simon evans goes to
market which is not a right-wing show
but i suppose it is in support of the
free market and it champions the
notion that markets have a role to play
in organizing our affairs which
you know authoritarian state command is
sometimes less able to do as efficiently
so it has its right-wing to that extent
you know and i've had uh i've been on
the new schools and so on so i've always
felt that you know i'm not
like kind of banned i don't have
pictures of myself with gaffer
you know to try and demonstrate that i
feel like i'm in silence you know like i
mean some sort of gulag
but and i i think like i'd say on the on
the last trigonometry that i was on that
i came to the defense
of the bbc to some extent and said i
think among other things
it probably has fallen victim to some
extent to conquest robert conquest
second law which just says that any
organizational institution not
explicitly dedicated to right-wing
pursuits
will drift leftwards over the course of
it that's great
well his all three of his laws are
brilliant the other two are that
everyone is conservative about that
which they know most about
and the behavior of most bureaucratic
institutions is most easily understood
if you assume it has been captured by a
cabal of its enemies
so which i think is also possibly
accurate for the bbc now but
he was of course he was a brilliant
writer he was the man who first exposed
the
the great terror of stalinism in the 30s
and 40s and all of british intelligence
you didn't want to have anything to do
with that
when his book was republished the great
terror in i think the 1990s and the
publishers asked him i don't know if you
know this story but they asked him if he
would like to change the title and he
said yes
let's call it i told you so you [ __ ]
fools
which was pretty trenchant and uh but he
also wrote brilliant uh light verse and
limerick's on uh which was anthologized
by kingsley amis so you know a man of
many talents anyway
that's what i thought the bbc was but
there was something about the way they
treated the most
you know the way they defended
themselves against the most recent there
was this thing that was supported tim
davey which may or may not even have
been true or may have been exaggerated
that he was concerned
that a certain kind of woke tendency
which is like i know it's a slightly
labored term but you know it is very
convenient shorthand
a kind of yeah the the the new uh
the the uh the new orthodoxy about about
certain political views which is okay or
not okay to hold
was dominating british comedy especially
a topical comedy
and the other views weren't being heard
and and he was anxious as well i think
which i think is as much as it to do
with anything that a certain kind of
juvenile
um attitude to those issues was was
predominant as well you know and the
middle-aged people were feeling hectic
by students essentially every time they
wanted to see some comedy
so this yeah this launched a thousand uh
think pieces
and i just noticed a a large number of
them containing my name
as an example of the bbc's determination
to bring balance to topical comedy
wherever possible
he said there are very few stamp
right-wing stand-ups for whatever reason
we just don't know
we just we just don't know for some
reason right-wing
views and stand-up comedy just don't mix
and presumably if you're
a right-winger you know you immediately
go into you know the the
privatized prison services or something
you know rather than
like trying to make people laugh but the
one or two right wingers that there are
which is to say me and jeff norco it
seems are never off our screens as a
result we are the beneficiaries of this
terrible you know gap this this terrible
market supply
problem which somehow market forces have
failed to meet as they normally would by
producing water supply
there's this terrible shortage and
consequently you never is
i haven't been on mock the week since
2011.
i have never been on uh have i got news
for you
i've never been on the mass report i've
never been on any
topical comedy bbc television program
at all or in fact for that matter any of
the itv or channel four ones
now i'm not saying i should have been
i'm not saying i have a right to be
i'm not saying this is the dereliction
of duty and the licensed peers the pains
are being
you know shafted by but if you're going
to present
me as the totem of your earnest
enthusiasm for finding balance wherever
possible
and i haven't been on a single program
in over a decade
that feels to me like dishonesty and
that was the point which something
started twitching in me and i just
thought i need to say something about
that because it's
it's just absurd you know you cannot
keep getting away with that
there is clearly some determination
to either remain like willfully
oblivious to the appetite that at least
half the nation by by definition if half
a left wing half a right wing you know
the center moves yes but you know by
definition
half a right of center if if you're
oblivious to their
weariness their fatigue at this endless
bias and you're fighting a rearguard
action to try and keep your license fee
in place then i don't see that that ends
well you see what i mean
so you're saying there's no right wing
privilege no i don't
believe there is i mean clearly you know
the old-fashioned right-wing privilege
still exists you know the aristocracy
are all right you know there is still
there are still landed classes maybe
there is still work to be done on that
front you know but um
but in terms of the voices that are
heard and it's not impossible you know i
was on the news quiz last week as i say
on radio i still get a sniff of it
i was on the news quiz and you know i am
confident enough in my performance to
say i think it went well
i don't think it felt like there was a
turd floating in the swimming pool
around which all the
the nice left-wing you know bien ponce
were
were forced to swim and and hold their
noses i think i combined pretty well
with
you know two other comedians three other
comedians uh an la comedian who
was kind of very progressive and does
mainly does routines about how donald
trump is going to end the world
we still manage to sort of engage and
and do what i mean there's not there's
not necessarily
some kind of oil and water issue here
where you just cannot combine these
ingredients to make a palatable
soup it's you know it it is better for
everyone
in this respect that diversity is
actually better for everyone you know
so why aren't we seeing it and so and so
now i feel like
i am much less patient with this
argument you know that they have than i
was two years ago which i think to some
extent then
there was an argument that you know if
you don't see representation if if
you see a certain kind of political view
is always the one that's funny
if it is taken as red i mean i remember
working on the 11 o'clock show never
appeared on it but i worked on it as a
writer that that must be what 15 or 16
years ago the 11 o'clock show was yeah
ricky gervais right and um and addie g
of course
you know and it was kind of mocked at
the time but it had some pretty good
moments well in the writers room
they had a board up on the wall i mean
it was a bit tongue-in-cheek but it was
there
which had like a dozen core propositions
which this show
finds funny and returns to in order to
do you know create jokes and they were
things like
john prescott is fat and likes pies you
know
it was that bold you know now they talk
you know labor new labour have been in
for a while at that point and they were
the
you know they were the the targets but
that's how writers rooms work
you know that's how these things once
you know they think it's all over was
exactly the same
certain football managers are fat and
eat pies certain football managers drink
too much
certain players could probably lose a
few pounds what i mean there's just
these core propositions you come back to
them again and again and again
and it becomes very hard to dislodge
them and i just think a lot of people
switch off after a while
and do you think that there is a
fundamental bias within the heart of the
bbc
yes a huge bias now i don't not well the
heart i suppose you might say i don't
think the news department is that badly
biased
i think in fact if anything you could
find evidence that some of its
you know highest-ranking high-profile
reporters may have a right-wing bias i
think you could probably say that nick
robinson engaged with right-wing
politics in his
in his youth you know i think he keeps
it under control but you know there are
they're having examples i love the way
you talk about it like some kind of
disease
yeah he keeps it up he keeps his
syphilis under control
i don't mean he keeps it under control
and then it's toxic but obviously in
interviews yeah
andrew neal they could probably i know
they've lost him recently i don't know
whether it's due to that i think he was
by
by a mile the best interview of the bbc
probably the best interview i've ever
seen tackling contemporary politicians
in the uk and
you know would be in the us as well i
think it's he's a great loss but i hope
he'll find you know
you know success with his new station
but um but yeah he obviously has some he
has some quite um
let's say skeptical views about certain
left-wing politicians and the quality of
people in
westminster as much as anything else you
know so yeah
the news and current affairs department
i think is is reasonably well balanced
but i think comedy and i think also
drama and i think like entertainment i
think
general radio 4 programming it just
displays
and it's a really and i think it's just
getting ridiculous now and i want to say
this is i say i'm scared i'm breaking
cover in a way knowing this is not going
to help my
pvc career they're not going to wake me
up oh we heard you complaining on the
podcast sorry with a bit of an oversight
let's get you on
but the fact is i love the bbc i grew up
with
like loving its programs everything from
blue peter and jack and ori you know up
to
all creatures grants more all of that
kind of stuff you know that absolutely
is my childhood and i think it performs
an incredibly valuable role
in british culture and society because
it because it doesn't have advertising
and because it doesn't have
you know uh you know the kind of
commercial forces that china is
currently able to bring to bear on
on on private media companies in america
now terrifying
degree of leverage that they have on
everything from basketball and football
right the way through to actual news
programming
you know you look at bloomberg and how
he downplays chinese authoritarianism in
order to keep
his business channels open with michael
bloomberg you know the actual individual
these are really worrying tendencies and
the bbc is our strongest ball work
against that but if it loses its
legitimacy by
you know be by just losing the good will
of half the nation
then it's in real trouble and it cannot
legitimately determine it cannot
legitimately demand
that the the license fee which is in
essential you know
in terms of taxes is is can be used to
fund it you know
i can see arguments for it against in
the background but but its primary
function at the heart of british culture
is enormously important to me
you know and so in exactly the same way
that i would actually reject the notion
that for instance ralph miliband hated
the country which
offered him safe sanctuary you know in
the night you know that whole daily mail
thing oh he came here and then
and then tried to undermine it with his
comp he came here but he loved the
country but he had communist views now i
don't share those views but i'm sure
they were
sincerely held and i'm sure he wanted to
improve the country that had
given him sanct you know sanctuary but
yeah yeah yeah exactly i mean it's
insane but
and i mean i think it's also it's also a
legitimate thing to raise incidentally
if you're trying to
decide whether to elect a prime minister
but but this is what i mean i mean i
feel like the reverse of that now i feel
like i'm i'm actually
saying to the bbc for god's sake you
need to get this under control because
you know i just i just see so many
people switching off now and totally
unable to
to trust it and you've seen what
happened in america you know
donald trump for the last four years i
don't
see him as like so much like a torch
that's been swung around down in the
basements and the cellars under
under the media in the deep state
whatever he's more like he's like thrown
down a
you know like one of those flare gup you
know if there's been an explosion it's
made a terrible mess
and you could very easily argue it's
done more damage than good but it is
it is i think incontrovertible that it
has illuminated
an extraordinary degree of bias in the
american media
there is no question now to my mind and
people talk about oh you've been
radicalized i've
only ever been radicalized by seeing
obvious explicit outright and naked
lying
on the part of the left i've never read
anything by anyone right wing that has
pushed me further right
do what i mean i've never occasionally
glass at katie hopkins article i think
this is rabid half semi-literate
nonsense yeah i have no interest
but i read the washington post in its
coverage of the commington high school
incident where those boys were like
approached by
the native american with his drum and
the way they promoted that as being
somehow some kind of bunch of
catholic high school boys bullying this
like political activist
that radicalized me yes i i was deeply
affected by that i was horrified
by the anger and the malice and the
the poison and the invective that was
directed at those boys
and the complete refusal of them to
acknowledge that they got it totally
wrong
when within 24 hours lots of video
evidence emerged that told the true
story
and that was just one example there's
been loads of examples of that and and
you don't want to go down that route
because america now
nobody acknowledges a universal
consensus about the media they can trust
there is not one single source of news
now in america
which more than 40 or 50 percent of the
country will say is a trusted source
and that is not a good start that is not
a good place to go to
i agree completely and that's one of the
reasons we've been talking about bbc and
the problems with the bbc because we
both feel passionately
like you that it's a hugely important
institution
actually i would go beyond even what you
said it's hugely important for keeping
britain together
yeah but but you know my grandfather
fled the soviet union because he
actually listened to bbc world service
he was a beacon of freedom yeah a lot of
people and still people talk about it in
those terms
radios here but equally that's why you
and i and francis we've all been warning
about
the path down which the bbc has gone
because it will destroy itself
yeah you know um but one of the other
interesting things about
the chat we had on the phone a few weeks
ago was that you were
somewhat skeptical about the noise being
made by tim davey and people on his
behalf and saying that
this is now this radical transformation
that will bring the bbc back from the
brink you
you're less uh persuaded by that are you
the only thing i would have to say about
about the tim davey remark
which then didn't really seem to
correlate closely with his speech when
it came he was this was like a sort of
teaser for a speech he was giving to
some conference i can't remember which
one
and it didn't seem to get a mention in
fact in his speech and
some people said of the telegraph have
taken this opportunity to
um you know go to one of their hobby
horses
which of course the telegraph have a
have a biased interest and they keep
commercial interest in seeing the bbc
fail so they would like to see that
happen you know
and you know can you trust them well no
you can't trust them that's half my
point
but you can't trust anyone at the moment
really without seeing some action
because
i don't know tim davey at all i've never
met him and i haven't really followed
his career up to this point he seems
like a decent chap and i think he has
the credentials you know
on paper to run run the show and and to
do that job but i don't know how serious
he might be or might not be about this
so you can't be
you know swayed by a press release this
is my point really you know
my wife works in pr i see how it works
all the time you know press releases are
sometimes put out to test the water
sometimes they put out
in instead of doing anything sometimes
they put out
put out deliberately i'm not saying
she's done this but i know the industry
sometimes they put out deliberately in
order to provoke such a strong reaction
against the idea of a thing happening
that it's retreated from before you know
what i mean it's deliberately done in
order to make the action impossible
now i don't know whether you would say
sorry i don't know whether you would say
that that has taken place with tim davey
i i it flared up and and in the time
since we we spoke it's died down again
a bit who knows what may or may not be
coming every so often you hit you see
stories in the media that um
paul mertman and uh and hislop have been
sacked from have i got news for you
because they're
uh they're seen as being old white men
and now there's going to be some new
box ticking woke alternatives that are
going to come in and this isn't true you
know it just isn't true and i don't know
whether any of these
stories that come out are have had any
kind of connection with anyone who even
you know puts the kettle on in the bbc
but
you you have to wait and see what
actually happens so yes i'm not i'm not
skeptical
specifically about this i just you know
this is just how the world of pr works
now
and how messaging is is controlled and
it is a dark art i mean it always has
been to some extent you know
and and confusion and befuddlement is
usually like the absolute first go-to
you know as everyone says big tobacco
playbook that's the first thing you cast
doubt on everything
you know you you find alternative
surveys and alternative findings and
everyone i hate to use it because it's a
term so beloved of the left but
gaslighting it just feels to me like
gaslighting which
if casual listeners don't know it comes
from a movie in which a man drives his
wife mad
by altering the environment around her
and then denying that he's doing so
basically he turns the gas he turns the
lighting down and she's convinced
things are getting darker and says no
it's exactly the same and she goes mad
now whether that would actually make you
mad or not is a moot point
people's nerves were a bit short after
the war but um
that happens a lot to us now we can all
see what's going on
but there are it's quite possible you
know it's quite people can sustain for a
long time
uh media campaigns that if you have
enough control of the argument of the
conversation
where it goes you can sustain the
impression that actually this is an
illusion you're suffering under
and and you're conspiracy theorist or
whatever you know when we all can see
exactly what is happening and it's
absurd to pretend otherwise
so you know i want to see actual action
before i see any kind of before i have a
view about whether tim davies is in
earnest not not that i'm saying i think
he's a liar or you know i don't think
he's up to the job
but i do think it'll be a bigger job
than he realizes because i think
the culture what we see what emerges
from the bbc and what emerges from
a lot of places like the universities
and so on at the moment
is not it's not a veneer this is coming
from deep inside this is coming from
you know the collective viewpoints the
collective mindset of
of the you know the sentiment that is
shared
throughout the organization you know
it's deep inside it's not because it's
not responding to some
memo saying make comedy more woke you
know so it's not like another memo going
okay that's enough he's back on the
that's not going to happen this is a
this is downstream
of the people who work there so unless
you're going to like sack everyone you
know
[Laughter]
go rushing on them when we started this
show
two and a half years ago we had one
dream
and that dream is now fulfilled finally
after all that hard work we're
advertising b
days and it's not just any b days it's
skoosh bing days
and not just scooch b days these are b
day
attachments which means that if you
don't have the space in your toilet for
a beading
maybe because you're an ordinary you can
get an attachment
and it's dirt cheap no pun intended and
it's far more hygienic for you to clean
yourself with
it's that easy to install it's
environmentally friendly and finally
since we're running out of paper
it's the perfect solution absolutely so
if you want
be hygienic and save the planet as well
alternative to toilet paper go to
skoosh.shop
that's scooch dot shop for all your
b-day needs
screw speed day are offering all
trigonometry fans at 10
discount just head over to their website
and enter
our code which is tpod1
to get your amazing discount that's
tpod1
to get 10 percent off of beda so glad we
finally achieved our dreams
but i suppose that leads into the
question you know tim david can come in
and he can try his best but haven't we
gone
too far down that's this particular path
in the bbc
well i don't know you have to be patient
you know there is this um
phrase the long march through the
institutions which sounds like paranoid
absurdity and if it had been invented by
somebody on the right i would say
probably was but given that it was you
know
coined by a a german marxist i think new
co
was his name deutsche what's up rudy
deutsch something like that it's
interesting interesting thing to look up
and he got it basically he was
synthesizing antonio gramsci uh writings
from sort of
1930s italy it's very interesting stuff
it's very
theoretical but you know you can see
it's not hard to map it onto the reality
we live in now the long march through
the institutions is basically the
proposition that you are never going to
bring about
a communist or left-wing revolution a
socialist revolution in the west through
the traditional means employed
in russia or china because contrary to
marx's views everyone is too comfortable
there's too much
cultural hegemony which was gramps his
phrase again
which is that there is too much
control by the universities by the media
by the government by the establishment
as they used to be described the various
instruments of soft power which to some
extent we still have
um who will make people averse to this
you know the idea that they should rise
up and burn everything to the ground
again and so instead what you have to do
is get your hair cut clean your nails
present yourself in a nice clean shirt
and tie and get a job
in the british library in the
universities in the bbc
and you are basically like sleeper
agents now as i say put like that it
sounds like right-wing proper you know
paranoia but as it becomes a kind of
as patience you know takes its time and
there's a certain kind of
shift in the mindset of the sort of
people who might be inclined to go into
the civil service changes i mean i was
at university in the mid-80s
and i think most people who went into
the civil service there i i
i regarded it as being i couldn't
imagine
having the whole world the opportunities
that it presented the different
kinds of career paths that you could
choose i studied law and you didn't want
to be a lawyer but i thought i'm going
to come out of this
as a graduate you know as a free man
with with like a
you know a wallet and a pair of boots
and i can go wherever i want to do
whatever i want
who would conceivably join the civil
service in that situation you know
and basically sign up for 35 years with
a nice pension
you know as the main prize so i do i've
never understood the kind of mindset of
people who might do that you know
never never overlap with me but they
were fairly sort of conservative i think
at that time you know but gradually over
time it has become
a role that's become more attractive to
people of the left you know it's become
more attractive to people with that kind
of mindset
and the more than there are the more
attractive it becomes and the more they
tend to get recruited and the more they
tend to see messaging that encourages
them to think that their kind of
thinking will be um welcome
and and that they will be able to get
some leverage on on the wheels of the
you know the levers of power will will
be available to them in a small way and
they will be able to make the difference
as they say they don't
see themselves as engaged in some sort
of you know conspiracy or or uh
or terrible sort of evil plan they think
they are doing god's work of course you
know this
but the right correct moral people have
finished yes exactly and we are now
able to educate children about the
correct way to think about sex and
gender from the age of seven and all the
rest of it you know
that has become you know a perfectly
legitimate role for anyone working
within the state sector now
so what we need i suppose what i'm
saying is is patience
you know these these are long long
fights and the pendulum is long and
swing slowly but it must eventually
swing
back again it may even conceivably
already have started i don't know i
i do see my my daughter is 16 and i see
in her generation
you know she is privately educated so
she may not be typical in that regard
but i do see
hey about which i have issues myself
before anyone
can but um i do see in her generation
generation zed or gen z as they you know
call them um
you know a good deal more skepticism
about about
this project you know the great
awakening than uh
than perhaps you know the people in
their late 20s early 30s or whatever who
were
you know i think they can already see
that um
that they are being uh you know
bossed around at the very least i think
there's a resistance to that that's
emerging i hope it's an interesting
thing talking about bias because one of
the things i'm aware and it's probably
way too late until the interview about
half an hour in
to explain to people who may not be
familiar with your work or your thinking
on things yeah that both you and jeff
norco who's a friend of ours as well
who you mentioned as the two sort of at
least claimed representatives of
right-wing comedy on
bbc and other channels you're both sort
of you are so more libertarian than
anything
yeah jeff is very much center-right so
neither
of you are sort of doing material on the
benefits of flogging and hanging well no
my
my stick to the extent that it was
political at all i suppose
things changed i've been doing it for 25
years i think the first 10 years i did
adopt quite an
arch persona which was obviously quite
ironic but was essentially almost a sort
of
um i mean i don't know if you know
julius evela he's a sort of 1930s
right-wing italian thinker i'd never
heard of him then but i've since
encountered him and he's quite comical
because some of his pronouncements are
just so sort of absurdly
you know dignified there's a famous one
that
that i adapted for my twitter bio in
which he said that now
my views are only those which prior to
the french revolution every well-born
person considered sane and norman
he said this in the 1930s but you know
that was kind of my shtick and it was as
i said it was very tongue-in-cheek but i
suppose what i would try and do as i say
again to the extent that it was
political was
express views that were like comically
of that kind you know comically
antiquated and archaic and aristocratic
rather than sort of right or left-wing
but also i suppose use those to puncture
some of this sort of sentimentality or
the absurdity of the left
and just you know just make a space in
which you could see the
you know how you could make that point
but that's my point sir which is that
neither you or jeff are sort of making
material about the importance of
creating the lebanese ram and poland no
no
that's not that's not well it was it was
brexit which i think created the thing
of course as it did for most of us and i
think jeff genuinely did vote brexit
and has made a perfectly sort of uh
clean
uh case for that and expressed his views
my thing of course was
i i didn't really vote i didn't vote
brexit i wasn't um
on the day of that itself i found myself
uh
unexpectedly stuck in london i didn't
vote at all but if i had voted i would
have voted remain
um but without any great enthusiasm but
you know i'd
i paid attention it was all it was to
some of the legitimate uh
arguments on on the brexit side and i
knew for instance my friend marin
somerset webb who's an ft columnist and
editor of money week who used to be my
guest on goes to market
she was an advocate for for brexit on
economic grounds
long-term economic grounds you know
always going to be bumpy but there's uh
but there are
huge gains to be had in her view and a
few other people of that kind and also
i was increasingly sick of people like
my father was in his late 80s and wanted
to vote brexit
you know being treated as just
unreconstructed racist you know and i
didn't think that that was where he was
coming from at all
you know so it was more like a defense
of a different point of view from my
point of view
right you know and just i mean you know
i'm in danger of sounding like a kind of
white knighting mentality
you know which is obviously very um
obnoxious but
i just felt there were certain people
who weren't getting properly represented
so i just sort of came out a little bit
in their favor
but um but brexit obviously you know
it divided everything and it redrew
every map and um or or rather it drew a
much much deeper chasm between two
halves of those
of that map it was it was like the
berlin wall going up
you know i think in the comedy business
and and in culture generally and i'm not
i still think to this day we are still
seeing many things through a brexit
prison which aren't really brexit at all
for instance
this is my view and i i i'm well aware
this might not um
i might not be able to sell this but i i
genuinely hold it dominick cummings when
he
had that whole like fiasco driving up to
uh durham with his kids and then going
to barnard castle for the day
which i think was unquestionably was a
day trip with his wife you know
regardless of the eye test nonsense but
the
hate the loathing the the the the
vitriol directed at him for doing that
after his rule supposedly we were
obeying his rules as if he come up with
them arbitrarily
you know because he thought that they
might be for our better good neil
ferguson who actually
insisted on those rules broke lockdown
there was no hatred and vitriol towards
him whatsoever it was basically he
that was quite funny that he allowed his
girlfriend his this married woman to
come in through his
french windows for a bit of hanky-panky
during lockdown when that was breaking
the rules
no question i'm sure he was right in
fact yeah but he had a decent motive
yeah
my point is my suspicion is the reason
that cummings was hated for the barnard
castle excursion
is because for a year for a couple years
everyone had thought
he will deliver a no deal brexit from
the consequences of which he will then
proceed to make himself safe and secure
he will not be the one feeling the food
shortages
unable to get insulin held up in a
20-mile tail back at dover
he won't none of that will apply to him
he will escape all of that
he will give us this absolute [ __ ] show
of a no deal brexit
and then he will abscond from all the
terrible consequences
and that hasn't even happened yet and
may happen and maybe he will do that i
don't know
but when they saw him go to barnard
castle that's what they thought they
were seeing
they thought they were seeing the mat
the mind they always knew that's what he
would do
he would it would be one rule for us and
one rule for him and they thought that's
what they were seeing
and that's how it's poisoned everything
you see what i mean it's like everything
is just seen through that lens now
and again not good not healthy at all
how nice to be talking about brexit
yeah it's been a while it's just key
it's like that gift that keeps on giving
it's always exciting for us when we get
to plug something
by one of our fans and today that man is
gregory coffin
and gregory is an author and he writes
both fiction
and non-fiction and they all have the
theme
of freedom and liberty within them
absolutely one of the novelties got four
particularly but one of them is called
the social carol
and this might sound familiar it's about
a protester
who wants to change the world and then
finds out that the world he's created as
a result
isn't quite what he was looking for
basically it's my story guys is what i'm
trying to say
when have you ever been to a prize mate
you don't leave the house no i don't
only to eat the books are available in
audiobook
print and ebook the brilliant thing
about the ebook is that it's
choose your own price absolutely go to
gdx1776.com
and get your books today absolutely
that's gdx1776.com i don't feel we said
absolutely enough during the course of
this ad
no we haven't that's absolutely true
we are three comedians here and we we've
touched on comedy yeah but we haven't
really delved into it
so it seems to me and maybe you'd
disagree with me on this but
the bias within comedy has just got
worse since the two years ago that we
spoke to you
yes i'm afraid i think that's true and
it's funny you know when the virus came
i think there was there was
there was a month or so i i suppose it
was probably
immediately prior to the to the death of
george floyd when
you felt that a lot of what you know
what the kind of fluff and
like loose hair we were all entangled in
had just been swept away and we were
brought back to fundamentals
you know we would suddenly see what was
important in life the the lives of our
live of our nearest and dearest and
keeping yourself safe and all the rest
of it
and it felt like a lot of the of the
noise that that had
you know might die away and we could all
just embrace albeit through zoom
you know and and and emerge into a new
reset and and it just did and then of
course it all just
it just exploded with ten times the
ferocity the
the black lives matter riots and then
the
statue toppling and then people against
the statue toppling and then
people believing that the mask wearing
was a
yet another attempt to authoritarian
control and
and there's just been an escalation now
of polarizing views i i think it's much
much was not just in comedy but
obviously that
the thing i would say about comedy is
obviously i know who
my colleagues are and i speak to some of
them on twitter but there is no comedy
as such at all at the moment i mean it's
gone
into in much the same way in the second
world war you know you had no football
i think i think it was arthur askey who
made his first broadcast in four years
from the
you know from broadcasting house you
know that all having been shut down
during the war and then said you know
anyway as i was saying before i was so
rudely interrupted you know
it feels a bit like that at the moment
and so of course we're all inward
looking we are
all trying to create uh we're all trying
to
let's be honest you know keep ourselves
in the public eye to some extent it's
quite difficult
to uh to do that with jokes you know
they are a bit lame one other thing that
was quite interesting i found
this is i don't this is off topic but um
in the first month or two
of of coronavirus and it's continued to
some extent in the first month or two
there was a sudden eruption of really
funny
memes and videos and like
shared online humor from anonymous
people none of it credited to anyone
you know some of it was classic internet
meme just a face of somebody famous with
a speech level
some of them were like people who'd done
like a a minute long tic talk video in
their house which was brilliantly
inventive some of them
people have made little models of people
moving around the house
incredibly inventive and not one of them
came from a recognized comedian as far
as i could see
to the extent that comedians did their
own stuff
it was a bit icky quite a lot of the
time there was a lot of egginess there
was a lot of sense that
ah without you know i said there's a
there was a famous saying when um i
think it was in 2008 that the financial
crash
somebody said it's like when the tide
goes out you can see who's been swimming
naked
and that's how i felt about comedians
without laughter track
you know if you don't have an audience
responding and saying that was funny do
it again
suddenly there's a kind of slightly uh
feeling you know and we're not used to
that we're
we're like tennis players you know we
need the ball to
come back over the net so we can punch
another low ground shot over it's like
we're not used to just performing in a
vacuum so we've had
we've had difficulty and one way to get
around that of course
is to become politically activated you
know to start doing stuff like
oh my god i can't believe you know we're
being asked to wear a mask
stroke i can't believe people are
refusing to wear a mask you know
it gives you something to connect with
it gives you something to engage with
and it makes you feel vital it makes you
feel like you're an important part of
people's lives and you know comedians
are you know we need to eat you know
he's i totally understand that you know
i'm
i don't know to what extent i may or may
not have got it right or wrong myself
but um
i haven't produced a huge amount of um
of like self-promoting content i have
written for a few online magazines
and you know i've tried to remain
active i've probably written more under
lockdown than i have done
in the previous 20 years you know month
by month for the pro rata basis i've
written about
30 35 000 words of what i you know is
considered content but um and it's not
it's not a whole book
but you know it's more than i normally
would do but you make the point simon
about
the the political angle because you know
i it's a it's i think it's a legitimate
point some of us i've always been
political with
with what i've done so it's not been a
thing for me but there has
there has seemed to be and as you said
particularly since blm and george floyd
a sort of uptick in in people's embrace
of that
people that i i friends and and
colleagues that that were never
political before
very political now and this is why i
want to come back to the bbc briefly
because there was this incident i don't
want to get into the
who said what and whatever because it's
not really that important i think it
just illustrates the point about
the bbc's angle on things there was this
instance on
frankie boyle's show new world order
where a black comedian was explaining
how when when people who are from that
point of view the blm point of view
say kill whitey they don't really mean
kill white people
and the joke was then we do yeah i saw
that yeah
and that created a stir and i just
remembered that the first time we had
you on
joe brand had just made comments about
nigel farage and sort of
they were sort of very similarly tinged
with the sort of
um yeah i defended uh joe brown at the
time but they were tinged with this idea
that
the joke was about hurting people
and what was your take on that situation
well we talked about joe brandon yeah
yeah and i also i defended her right to
it but while while
uh you know observing that she had
herself um
you know uh brought people to account in
quite a decisive way previously for
things they'd said
and also you were critical of the
producer yeah which was interesting
because this time i was critical of the
producer while again defending the
comedian's right to do a joke
and i got a lot of pushback on that as
supposedly i'm this free speech
warrior and now i'm saying i watched um
frankie boyd's new world order and i
think it's
i'll be honest i think it's a show of
two halves i think frankie's monologues
are amazing they're
densely packed incredibly uh rich in
analogy creative language
you know there's there's almost like a
kind of magic realism
to them or you might say oh like they're
very elusive they're very
uh they're almost biblical you know they
they remind me of like
hard reigns gonna fall or something do
what i mean the way that dylan would
channel browning or the old testament
that they have that kind of density
which is really rare in language
funnily enough russell brand is capable
of it when he puts his mind to it as
well you know
there's another like man on the left who
has been on a more interesting journey
in my view i think frankie is a really
talented comedian i hope he won't mind
me acknowledging that he also has i
think a very good writing team on that
you know show and that's perfectly
natural and normal it's about creating
the best product
and i know some of those writers and i
think it's a really those monologues are
amazing
i think frankie himself in my view is
not really a man of the left i think
he's a total nihilist i think he made
quite a considered and probably
correct judgment at a certain point in
his career that he couldn't continue
to just like degrade everything without
any sort of sense of
having any sort of focus or distinction
between what was deserving and what
wasn't
and so at that point he basically threw
his weight behind releasing political
prisoners from guantanamo and everything
else was late to it
you know but i'm not saying it's
insincere but that's my that's my
impression that makes the most sense to
me when i look at the arc of his career
but that show has become weird now where
you get that monologue
and that's very funny and engaging and
thought-provoking and i have no quarrel
with it being one-sided because it's
obviously you know that's what it is
it's an author of peace
and then there's this kind of weird
round table discussion which feels much
more like some kind of 1960s marriage
struggle session
in which sarah pascoe is expected
repeatedly to acknowledge her white
privilege and all the rest of it you
know
by a series of ever more didactic
you know critical theory experts i'm
interested that you say that woman was a
comedian because she didn't come across
like a comedian at all she doesn't come
across like somebody who wants to make
people laugh
when she said when we say kill whitey we
don't mean it we do
i mean people laugh but it was the way
you laugh at somebody who is like
you know at a meeting and says something
funny about the real
but suppressed for the purposes of pr
intentions of the group
now i don't think it necessarily
shouldn't have gone out i don't see it
as a genuine incitement to kill whitey
you it might have had some connection to
that terrible event in east croydon a
little while later who knows i don't
know i'm not pinning that on them
i can just say if it were on the left if
that had been
the sort of thing that somebody had said
about brexit uh just before uh the
the mp was stamped up in the north of uh
joe cox then
you know um i i wouldn't be surprised if
some people have drawn
connections between the bbc broadcasting
that and that happening
i mean who knows but it what it's
it's an extraordinarily you know wide
definition of comedy what goes on that
show right now it feels like it's a very
very
politically motivated and unadorned
you know discussion of events from a
certain political perspective and as i
say
that would be fine perhaps to a degree
if there was anything at all
from the other side if there was any
attempt to put on comedians
who were as well informed and well-read
and well-referenced
in libertarian points of view or
right-wing points of view or
conservative points of view or let's say
roman catholic points of view
or just centrist point or even just a
census point of view to say why
black lives matter actually has certain
elements
in its credo which we should be very
careful of introducing into our schools
and playgrounds
before we wholeheartedly endorse the
capitalized version of that slogan
you know i just think that these this
just you've got to have some kind of
pushback against
material of that of that degree of of uh
that strength i suppose you know that
purposefulness
and i'm going to present you with the
counter argument now the counter
argument to your point would be
that really comedy can only be left-wing
because the entire point of comedy is to
mock to satirize the people in charge
and power
and we have been in a conservative
government now for 10 years the right
are the ones who hold power
therefore the only truly authentic
position is to be on the left
comedically
do you agree i think was it swift or
somebody of that era who said that
satire is a sort of mirror wherein
everyone perceives
uh any every face but their own
something like that not not necessarily
initially felt
not necessarily to be i know yes um what
is it like uh
to discomfort the comfortable and vice
versa or something like that
and comfortable you come for the
afflicted and afflict the comfortable
satire to me and i mean satire is quite
a narrow definition anyway and does it
even exist or does it come and go or you
know
would it would could you honestly say
for instance what the weak is satire
i don't mean that in a harsh way
honestly it delivers a lot of laughs you
know pound for punch
but um
satire for me at any rate should be
of the human condition what
the fundamental purpose of comedy is to
make us aware of how ridiculous
life is how ridiculous we all are how
ridiculous all our aspirations are
how ridiculous the aspirations of a tory
government
that comes in with a huge elected
majority and has an incredible
budget in which they essentially steal
all of the left's clothes
and present the red wall with a massive
payday for their electoral loyalty
and within a month are destroyed by a
once in a century
medical event that nobody could have
foreseen coming whatsoever
all of their aspirations and hopes and
glories you know just reduced to dust in
that respect
that's funny you know and so too is it
funny
when alf garnet wants to just try and
get through his sunday afternoon without
being interrupted by the bloody
jehovah's witnesses
a man of that low status with his tiny
aspirations but still unable to pursue
them
it's all so funny you know comedy is
about our absurd
inflated view of ourselves as having any
command and control over our own
our own fate and fortunes whatsoever you
know i watched a good film
a couple of nights ago a cohen brothers
movie called a serious man
which i've been thinking about a lot
which kind of deals with those issues
and about the the uh insanity of of
pursuing meaning
or coherence in life you know this is
what a lot of comedy
should and traditionally has been about
you know it's what samuel beckett's
plays are about you know
high art can go there but so too can
gordon simpson
you know step to and son had aspirations
it was only because
young stepso had such huge aspirations
that that
series remains such a high water mark in
british comedy
he is funny you you now you would go
well that's punching down stepped on
sound how could it be more punching down
these two men are
the most like absolutely on their uppers
the most economically marginalized and
vulnerable people in society
that wasn't how they saw themselves you
know and that made the
show funny were far far too
preoccupied now with this kind of what
is essentially a critical theory matrix
you know of oppression dynamics
where does the power lie in any
situation and that will tell us and this
is why when you go to a comedy show like
unleashed you know where
which to be honest is not nearly as kind
of
provocative as it pretends it might be
sometimes but it's just funny puts on a
good bill
there is this gale of laughter when
anyone says something which they know
they probably shouldn't laugh at and
we're not talking about
racism or sexism or rape jokes to be
honest you're more likely to see a rape
joke at jimmy carr live show or in fact
a frankie boyle live show that you are
unleashed but you see jokes you know
that just make you laugh before you run
through all the [ __ ] roller decks in
your head to see whether it's okay to do
so
that's why comedy is necessary you know
because it reminds us
it's a it's a it's a truth which we
struggle to repress
most of the time that's usually what
breaks out in the middle of a comedy set
you know
and we're so in the last 10 15 minutes
in the home straight if you like i mean
one of the things we were talking just
as we're sitting here
as uh before we started uh and you
mentioned
it in the interview itself which is you
talked about how you don't expect the
bbc to watch this and to go
let's get simon on this and yeah and
whatever
there is a price that can be paid by
people who are critical of this
critical race theory stuff and you
talked actually
you know to us about how it's not even
your own career that you're so much
concerned about now
you know that there's a price to be paid
by families of people here who speak out
against this
uh no i would say i mean i'm not no kind
of physical threat
to my family but i'm aware that you know
yeah some people might say oh i saw your
husband described as a right wing
committee is not right-wing is he
you know well i'm not saying i am
right-wing or i'm not but you know those
conversations can be uncomfortable even
that
right-wing which i mean probably yes i
am
you know in in historical terms i have
probably
sat center-right to most governments
that i've lived through you know even as
everything has drifted leftwards in my
view but that's you know is another i
suppose moot point
and i suppose that's one of the reasons
that few people are willing to
to be as open as you are about your
concerns
uh because i i know a lot of people
share
certain views about let's say diversity
quote unquote
in inverted commas about things that are
happening but it's very difficult to
discuss number one without being
punished directly
and number two without also sounding
like a sort of bitter middle-aged white
man
yeah where you're going why i haven't
been given this opportunity even though
and i have no skin in the game anymore
because i'm not really doing the comedy
strictly speaking in that sense even
though we all know that some people are
promoted because of who they are rather
than because of how skilled they are you
know so
we seem to be in this environment where
it's very difficult to to be open about
these things
really yeah certainly and the diversity
thing you know i don't think
i don't know anyone who has a quarrel
with diversity that emerges naturally or
even i think perhaps to some extent he's
given a helping hand maybe
if for instance posters went up in
schools encouraging young black kids to
think that there was a job for them in
the bbc
i mean the bbc have made an awful lot of
um
progress as they would see it maybe it
is uh in terms of getting uh
representation on the screen there is
still an enormous lack of diversity
in the production and in the board in
the boardroom in
you know in all the management that you
know that at that level they could
probably do to encouraging some people
that might not be such a bad thing
but it does become a racket there's
there's no question about it it becomes
a racket you know there's that great
old phrase i can't remember the guy's
name but every great you know every
great movement
starts as a cause sorry every great
cause starts as a movement becomes a
business and ends up as a racket i can't
remember the guy's name i wish i could
american sort of philosopher
and uh and it's about a newspaper man
probably
and you know that's where we're at you
know there is huge amounts of money
huge amounts of money now to be made
essentially
it's classic rent seeking you know
you're not bringing any value you're not
creating wealth you're not
improving the lot of mankind you are
interfering with with processes but in
order to do so and in order to maintain
your legitimacy you have to come down
very hard on anyone who says anything
i have friends for instance a criminal
barrister who was recently forced to go
on an implicit bias training
thing you know where they sit in front
of the computer and you find out whether
you have uh you know how
you are yeah this stuff has been
like it's it's been thoroughly
debunked i mean there is no question
about it at all there are very very
substantial studies which have
proven beyond doubt it doesn't work
it doesn't a it doesn't demonstrate
anything meaningful about how
deep rooted deep-seated somebody's
racist and prejudice
opinions might be and it certainly
doesn't improve their behavior
afterwards
you know they come out having had a
nasty shock you know or maybe or
whatever or being told that you know
and nothing nothing improves but there
is loads of cash in it and i remember
like
you know two or three years ago i
overheard people at the bbc canteen
talking about having been on one of
these things
and how it was fascinating because
people it's a human behavior thing to my
mind as well
as much as anything else people are
fascinated by themselves
you know everyone is catnip you know
especially to a certain kind of
demographic
youngish people usually you know just
fascinated oh it turns out look but
i'm i've i've got this and you've got
that you know what i mean they're all
people concert it's like astrology it is
it's literally like astrology it has no
greater claim to intellectual
foundations than astrology but it has it
taps into exactly the same curiosity we
all have about ourselves
and it's become a vast bracket and and
in order to sustain that yes they will
come down very hard and you get that
kind of
thing you know which we all know about
now like white fragility probably the
highest you know
uh mode of it the final form of it where
where
any attempt to resist the the narrative
only goes to prove how deeply embedded
in
in the in the floor you are you know
white fragility written
of course itself by a white woman and
and one who collects
vast fees to lecture people about how
their fragility is preventing them from
seeing the truth about their
you know their their privilege
bad it's bad it's not good these are not
good these are not good
trends at all bad we need to raise
productivity in this country
you raise productivity and everyone
starts feeling better off the feel good
factor that you know that tony blair had
that was an economic
factor that was an economic reality
raise productivity improve everyone's
lot
we we urgently need to address the
housing situation in this country and
redistribute the wealth a little bit
around the country and across the
demographics i totally get that i think
this is
i think a lot of this reflects the
terrible hand that's been dealt with
young people and certainly if you look
over the last 10 or even
30 years you know you see the top 1
have absolutely creamed off all the ex
extraneous wealth
all the new wealth that's come into the
economy in the last 10 years in
particular since the crash
has gone straight to the top one percent
not even like to the headmasters or
barristers or
local newspaper editors you know who
used to be considered to be solidly
middle class you know the acacia avenue
guys with their umbrella and the
morning day you know slightly boring and
stayed but you know
knew we had a decent pension to look
forward to those people have been
shafted every bit as much as the kids
have you know
there's no wonder they feel this the
system is rotting but it's not to do
with
like the the issues that black lives
matter is you know it's not to do with
police brutality not in this country
certainly it is to do with economic
you know some really deep-seated
economic problems that are not being
addressed and i think a lot of
the deal with woke capital as they call
it you know like the banks happy to put
up flags for gay pride and everything
you know is because they're really happy
for you to focus on that [ __ ]
and not notice what's actually going on
which is the capital accrues value
faster than labour can keep track with
that's the problem we're facing you know
that's the difficulty and the only way
it was solved in the past was with world
war
so we really need to get to grips with
that instead of hurting all these
distractions which is
you know which is where we're at at the
moment as a saying is why i think
you know the whole edifice of the
establishment is now behind the woke
movement because it's an amazingly
successful distraction from the actual
issue we need to address
and so how do we move forward simon well
he's already
told you world war ii world war ii
certainly well i don't know
general winter is back whatever that
accident
it is funny i have found myself reading
endlessly books about summer of 1914
the lesser known of the brian adams
songs what's coming that's right
yes but my first real sixth string but i
had nothing to plug it into
so that was no but you're right simon i
mean wealth
and income inequality you can be on the
right or left
it's toxic to harmonious societal
relations it kills everything
yeah and the evidence on that is very
clear and unless we address that we're
going to be screwed
and that's why a lot of us have been
talking about the economic impact of the
lockdown
yeah because that's only going to make
things worse it's made it much worse and
i'll be honest with you
i will say this you know a little bit
tongue-in-cheek but the truth is
this virus left to its own devices would
essentially have been quite benevolent
towards mankind in the long
run because it was absolutely focused
and targeted at the elderly
you know it would have it would have
been like a bad flu we would have had a
bad winter flu there would have been
a lot of people would have gone a year
or two before it was maybe their time
otherwise many of them already
living in the hell of dementia and um
and
two or three years later people would
probably have moved on
and nobody would really have felt that
there was any great terrible tragedy
a few people yeah but we've looked at
the statistic way less than a thousand
people in this country have died
under the age of 70 with no
co-morbidities that is not a public
health emergency
you know the the last time i was here
this thing i said nobody is paying
attention to is the demographic shift
in you know the elderly social care
the the ownership of property being held
by the elderly you know
young people unable to move forward this
is a massive societal problem
and this virus could actually have
solved it but we've buggered that up now
you know how he said he's not really
right-wing
i think he is i think what would have
happened what would have been the best
solution you know funnily enough the
best policy was the one that boris
johnson laid out to philip schofield and
holly willoughby on this morning
a couple of days before neil ferguson's
phone call came through we should have
toughed it out heard immunity the
elderly and vulnerable should have
locked down
and self-isolated we should have gotten
you know
systems in place meals on wheels or
whatever to keep them looked after and
and everyone else should have cracked on
with it i honestly think that would have
been the best solution
we have now absolutely shafted young
people they have inherited an even
vaster debt than the one they already
had
loads of the kind of jobs that they
always wanted to get into have just
disappeared
zoom and all that kind of stuff the
absence of commuting a move to home
working may or may not be like a viable
way to move forward and it could be part
of the great reset that avoids the
you know the cataclysmic climate change
that has been on the table for some time
that may be a good long-term solution
but i don't think it's healthy for young
people not to be going to work places
where they can engage with others a lot
of
office romances and so on you know are
not ever going to kind of
yeah get
kindled via zoom you know i think it's a
you know
a huge amount of of and london in
particular you know was like a real
young person's i mean they were
they were getting shafted on the
property and everything yeah but they
were all coming here regardless because
it was like it was absolutely cooking
you know places like shoreditch were
like world centers of excellence for
young people having ideas and using
their vitality to
create new you know all kinds of new
modes and idioms
of um of profit and and
that has just been slammed you know i
think it's a terrible terrible error a
terrible error
and and again one which a lot of people
who feel that way
feel unable to speak about because you
know oh you want to kill your granny
you know there is there are lots and
lots of different ways in which
government programs can kill people and
they aren't always immediately obvious
you know but
you've seen what's happened in america
you know the rust belt the opioid
addictions the deaths of despair have
rocketed over the last few years and
almost certainly
played a huge part in leading to donald
trump which is what everyone says they
don't want to happen over here
you know and that's what you're going to
get i suspect you know it's not
it's not a total coincidence that
fascism emerged out of the
the great depression not it's that's a
slight over
over simplification you know the
collapse of empire as well but
it was it was a big part of it and on
that rather cheerful note
i don't i don't have any finish with a
song
yeah buddy can you spare a dime
um we always finish with the same
question which is what's the one thing
we're not talking about as a society but
we really should be
well i mean i suppose in a way i've just
said it the i said last time that it was
the demographic shift towards the
elderly because
it's the least glamorous um demographic
shift
people are actually quite happy to talk
about changes in race changes in
religion the rise of islam and the
collapse of christianity across the west
those kind of issues
feel they feel um dangerous they feel
risky you know you feel a free song
when they come up and you're worried
that somebody might say something
unacceptable
but people are quite excited about them
talking about old people
just like living for 30 years after
retirement and and
uh and and the uh
the our failure to address that whatever
that's coming in
i think is only got worse since i think
it i think the care home fiasco with
with uh you know basically sending in
you know
patients with i mean it was almost like
i remember
um winston churchill in one of those
books i mentioned i've been reading a
lot earlier i love this quote uh
referred to lenin as being like a plague
bacillus
who was sent in in a sealed carriage
into russia by the germans in order to
create their downfall and um
i mean that's what i think about every
time i think about the you know
the treatment and and the whole approach
to it but of course the
the truth is it's something nobody wants
to address it's very easy to get angry
with the government or to get angry with
the local authorities
for uh their callous treatment of the
elderly but they wouldn't be in those
homes in the first place if a certain
degree of callousness was not already
in evidence from the society that
doesn't feel it has a place for them you
know they're basically in cold storage
waiting to die there's no escaping it
we've seen panorama does it like once
every 18 months you know
none of these places are like very
pleasant
so i'm afraid i'm gonna have to say that
again i still think it's that we are not
talking about how we are dealing with
demographic shifts
and you know we are not having children
and
we are not dying you know that that is
not
an ultimately long-term sustainable
situation
that's a good point you reminded me of
there was a comedian
who i used to gig with who had a joke
about how he's uh he's put his
mum in home and it must be a good one
because it's been in the news
[Laughter]
you're right you're right uh simon thank
you so much for coming back
thank you i'd like to plug at this point
oh god
your twitter is just remind everybody
just follow my twitter at the simon
evans and if you want to read my patreon
stuff
the top tweet there the pin tweet will
tell you exactly where you can find that
um and uh but uh yeah everything else
comes through there anyway that's where
i spent most of my day
fantastic simon's so good to have you
back thanks see you guys for
uh very soon with another brilliant
episode or a live stream all of those go
out at 7pm uk time
take care and see you soon guys
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word